l'épisode précédent la raf finalement
retrouvé ses amis mais après avoir
réussi à ouvrir ou plutôt mystérieuses
ils font tomber dans une embuscade
lara va bien évidemment s'en sortir
vivants elle va retrouver un ex amie à
elle s'est en fait bouffer la jambe par
un loup juste avant elle va alors allé
le chercher des médicaments qui étaient
un peu en hauteur à cause des loups et
ensuite cette amie va lui demander
d'aller en haut d'une tour à ce jour
pour lancer un sos
lara va-t-elle réussir à aller jusqu'à
la tour radio mais surtout celle ci va t
elle être en état pour pouvoir faire le
sos nous nous le demandons et nous
serons dans cet épisode
john woods s'est excusé inscrit
aujourd'hui pour l'épisode 3 de tomb
raider avec notre héroïne lara croft
alors la dernière fois souvenez vous on
s'était retrouvé dans ce caveau juste -
c'est un petit peu le son du jeu voilà
parfait pour être dedans là dans
l'ambiance
alors on était en va là bas dans les
commentaires on m'avait dit qu'il
fallait vous allez sauter ici à lui mais
l'acteur enfin allumés notre torches
allumées les cadavres qu'il ya ici et ça
monte et on allait pouvoir atteindre ici
le kof qui se trouve juste là dans
lequel on va trouver mais 250 xp voilà
voilà alors on va retourner en dehors de
la grotte
enfin du tout beau temps bon mois alors
c'est parti je sais plus où on en était
au niveau 2 des quêtes
alors attendez je découvre avec vous
papa même là je vois rien fait sur moi
il met le feu
j'avais fait un bail ça doit être par là
ouest et du squelette
j'aime la grotte la femme qui marche au
milieu des squelettes
alors j'ai peut-être une vie une vidéo
surprise pour vous sur tomb raider
d'ailleurs je n'en dis pas plus ça on
fera un homme boxing de fou malade alors
appuyé sur une fois les emplacements des
récompenses sur la carte on mais voilà
je m'en fous
alors [ __ ] haïdar c'est vrai qu'on
allait faire ça c'est chiant quand on
est dans le noir et où elle marche à
deux à l'heure elle se méfie wind et
n'ayant ni instinct de survie a tenu le
sommet à huy [ __ ] voilà on était à
cette foutue cascades valoir qu on
escalade alors je sens le truc un petit
peu parmi eux on va pouvoir apprendre à
jouer avec ça je souffre je vous
rappelle qu'on avait amélioré notre
fiolet temps qu'on avait eu un nouveau
bios les pardons qui nous permettait
d'aller de grimper les grandes façades
comme ça là notamment de sauter et de
faire x pour se rattraper que le violet
c'est hyper stylé par contre ça niveau
gameplay
j'avoue que c'est assez fort donc on
monte on entend montante on prend les
flèches ses ennemis au maire d' il a des
ennemis
mais
hello dernier excusez moi je suis
concentré commun qu il est là môme
merde je suis repéres et ta gueule non
in the faith ok parfait
alors est ce qu on a repéré comment ça
se fait qu'il ya du monde qu'est ce
qu'ils font là il ne cherchait
apparemment [ __ ] de merde c'est la
guerre c'est la guerre
on va ramasser les corps trouvés un
petit peu des matériaux obbadi dont on
peut qu il m'a lâché un truc qui brille
au nom au dge au cash
eh ben j'ai bien failli tu vois je t'en
fous oui on va aller wyeth a misé roi va
aller prendre le jeu peut pas invoquer
doigté 9 tu va se décanter dans l'eau
dans tu sais pas nager
ouais on va ramasser ce cadavre la oil
and lost et j'essaie de faire un truc
pas trop mal au montage quand même que
plus et voir une carte
absolument on n'a pas le temps pensé
conneries l'on va monter en la falaise
alors c'était la falaise ok on va passer
par là est ce qu'on peut souhaiter d'ici
faire x ouais perfect aller au monde
zut je te dis de bonté
comme ça mon temps mon temps mon ton
monte alors on va continuer ça faudrait
le brûlé il ya du feu on va le brûler
mais 10 de brûler ces trucs là ce que je
ne fais jamais alors je vous écoute on
voit la tête avoir des matériaux quoi
web ainsi la question logiquement ouais
d'accord ok top year obama il ya un truc
qui brille sur le toile en dessous on va
y aller oued et géocache je sais pas
trop à quoi ça sert mais ça doit on les
bat à non oh merde
d'accord on va s'accrocher à n'importe
quoi je vais m'accrocher à l'accueil de
jazz archie dos tourné là je suis là la
x parfait alors je parlais pas pendant
les cinématiques et j'essaierai à
d'activer les sous titres je vais faire
tout de suite options d'affichage sous
titres oui voilà c'est fait vous l'avez
demandé
jallet fait m pendant que j'y pense
comme ça car à des dialogues on vous
pourrez lire tranquillement que c'est
vrai que le son il n'est pas très fort
du coup vous déjà juste pour ma voix il
faut qu'on soit là pour monter là pour
monter là ok d'accord ce parfait up
j'adore ce que les je me demande qu'on a
là encore nouveau pioli ce qu'on gagne
en plus peut-être ou ses t shirt espèce
de pioche que ménard wow punaise ça
tombe
j'ai sauté trop tôt me manque comme une
merde [ __ ] bâton avec des fesses
pareil on meurt pas comme ça on tombe
sur les fesses c'est quoi ça aux caisses
de la sécu f1 c'est bon le mans ouest en
violet ouah super classe j'apprécie
énormément
ouais on a les sous titres ils sont
moches ouais tu y as trouvé ça on est
toujours sur sa trace
ok une idée tu vas devoir trouver la
console de communication de ça ressemble
à ce que je connais sa livebox
je la trouve on va descendre il ya des
flèches les flèches et c'est lui les
chiens savent à peu beach vous savez
quoi les gens quittaient être opéré
autant l'être complètement salut parfait
alors je suis au la vache hausse et pris
une arête dans les fesses agit pas
apprécié du tout ça par contre à la
vache même une flèche mais une date
heart on va attendre maintenant on est
plein on les plaint jean roque on va
continuer on va voir si on peut dire
c'est bon ça faudrait [ __ ] le feu on
va aller mais notre torche merde c'est
super coup je trouve ce système de
matériaux pour améliorer son arc ou quoi
c'est trop cool
du coup tu fout le feu à tout jeu le
pyromane au pardon alors on va péter
lesquels sont en train de mater au bas
du dos on va pouvoir faire les deux
améliorations pour l'arc
on verra ensuite pour le premier truc
ici que se cache non l'accord entre à
marc machin
on verra ensuite pour le gun j'ai un
mauvais pressentiment
ouais ça va ça semble aisée mais là
d'une question la gauche cinématiques
alors elle y est cette fameuse tour pour
lancer le sms ou pas à la caméra
et le vent souffle à dans la prairie
c'est mécanique
c'est pas un problème électrique
maintenant alex ok peut-être que c'est
un problème et les 93 bonjour way à
bichât c'est ma fille
elle a 14 ans fouchier est les plus
débrouillards que toi oh non je rigole
et nature de geek c'est pas attention à
lui comment et oui je vais aller voir ça
c'est un problème électrique il est
fiché le pauvre elle est mignonne les 14
donc j'étais sur le lac pour une partie
de pêche nocturne
c'est l'heure de fermer les écoutilles
j'arrive tout de suite donc j'étais sur
le lac
cette chose arrive vers moi et commence
à sortir de l'eau alors je lui ai mis un
coup de boule
oui je vous assure comme ça sur dix ça
marche ça marche
un bonze de la gueule mais je m'en bats
les couilles à livre à une baston
faisait
alors pour faire une prise s'il vous
plaît vous a pris en flag
merci docteur whitman séquence 15 prises
3 et actions alors vous le tenez bien et
vous l'ouvrez le ventre comme ça noémie
vous touche c'est couper le poisson je
vais le chercher
je n'ai qu'un poisson super bien faire
cet été je me ferais jamais je suis
censé apporter de la culture aux chances
sam pas cuisiner sans vouloir vous vexer
le public veut voir des choses docteur
whitman vous
en attendant de trouver le royaume perdu
nous n'avons pas vraiment le choix
est-ce pour avoir de l'argent pour voir
finances accord on s'arrangera au
montage vous aurez l'air d'un vrai chef
vous verrez docteur james pitman
séquence 15 prises quatre actions alors
tenez le fermement et tranchées lui
vendra
beau coup de couteau c'est parce que je
les vois encore quand je ferme les yeux
et si jamais le lien bataille ne se
trouvait pas d'entrer en du dragon je me
souviens du jour où tu as trouvé ça sur
un chantier tu as couru pour venir me le
montrer dans ton pyjama pingouins
j'avais tout juste cinq ans c'était mon
premier trésor
tu as beaucoup d'instinct barras il faut
tu crois en toi qu'est-ce que ça super
stylé a quand même ambition de l'arast
comme ça va c'est moi qui s'échouent au
risque de se tromper il aurait été très
fière de toi là j'espère que les sous
titres vous plaisent la tempête n'est
plus très loin
je vais pour vous allez ne t'inquiète
pas on s'en sortira
tout à fait c'est avec la tempête n'est
plus très loin quand même
ceci dit cela il va se coucher jeux vont
faire naufrage dans la nuit devant ce
quiz ouais alors on va jouer ce soir ça
n'a pas des pistes d'amélioration non
j'en ai déjà mis de aufait tard on va
pour améliorer son arc
j'ai déjà mis deux améliorations quand
vous êtes en avant la vidéo je sais plus
lesquels d'ailleurs mais je sais pas
mais ghaouti bon bah alors on peut
améliorer le piolet à 100 l'a déjà fait
alors on va le faire des améliorations
de l'arc alors l'arc permet un tueur
plus puissants entraînant plus de dégâts
un cac it l'accord renforcé offre une
garantie sur plus rapide à caquette voir
le pistolet maintenant le chargeur plomb
contenant du bas la convention récupère
d'ailleurs appris ces zones de monter
les dégâts kakek tu rapide à carrick à
catherine ashton a quelques noms tant
pis alors hop et pop pop pop pop pop pop
alors est ce que dans cette petite boîte
on peut prendre quelques noms au oui une
balle c'est un mec qui a mis une boîte
ici il a dit je mettrais hunt charles
valladont d'accord
on verra tout ça plus tard là j'aime pas
trop moi ça ces pièces a pas le monde
s'en fout 8 ok donc on vient de là bas
il faut qu'on aille là-bas aux [ __ ]
non c'est pour ça que je vais faire je
prends mon arc
on n'a pas manqué
war ou est ce qu'on peut je me tâte là
puisqu'à est une flèche aux maladies oui
de retirer le à d'accord ok c'est ça
qu'on peut viser hyper longtemps
maintenant plus autant qu'avant non mais
c'est quoi
non je pense que ouais mais là le flash
va nous voir mais son tir en flèche au
monde va comprendre sa dépouille
on l'a eu
on l'a eue crossman herbe
ok on a eu waouh
on fait des avis de minutes hier
ok ok on les emmène en a pas de panique
à la barre ce lara croft qui débarque
ça va tu veux pas trop mal soit un mec
alors ce qu'on peut lui mettre une
flèche dans son cul à l'homme ou triumph
ou deus au pif
c'est un pas marché on va se rapprocher
mais un psychologue touche pour faire
des roulades cp au hockey on y est on
ramassera les kadhafi tard
cherche un moyen est pensée pour toi
oh oh oh no oh non mais sérieux le mec
mais comment va le faire là alors quoi
allo à 2013 2013 des pêches dans les
dents non non non au fond on s'enfonce
en fonçant fait son combat le soir lara
la matu presse l'art à leur âge compte
sur toi ouais voilà alors d'erreurs il
faut vite descend alors on fait moins le
malin toi depuis l'arabie treillet tiens
ok c'est bon
mais ils arrivent en nombre il est au
volant collègues forme chaque cas là bas
car ça c'est le mec qu'on fait ça exprès
pour faire peur l'ombre je t'ai pas vu
c'est bon c'est bon car tout cas me
tiens tiens tout cas voilà pour le prix
d'un c'est la nouvelle promo chez
travailleurs compagnie ouais je trouve
ma blessure reste hardcore [ __ ] alors
on les a eus on va ramasser quand même
tous cas sur eux y compris ceux dans la
cour faut aller où la fois le sommet
faut aller là où en plus juste là au co
op hutin j'aime pas ça ok nous manque on
fait des sauts plutôt long le girafe va
monter là haut une pièce au passage -
croyable c'est quoi ça géocache tu peux
m'accrocher à ses concurrents non pas du
tout alors tu as qu'est la dsi suppose
mais non
mais pas du tout même laissez moi avec
les chiens il reste quand je suis plutôt
la non d'accord alors attendez faut
aller ou faut aller là-haut donc le
jugement pourrait on est obligé de
monter par cet escalier
or là je sens l'énigme à la con que
c'est le genre de truc tu passe deux
heures alors que ça pourrait être fait
en deux minutes aux chiottes au chili ap
comment on peut faire ça oh merde c'est
bon on a fait alors autant monté par là
les gens remercier moi je viens de vous
éviter environ 10 minutes de vidéo pour
rien j'ai cherché partout comme monter à
ce poste qu'un de sommeil de merde est
en fait la solution c'est juste tu
sautes le pont tu continue tout droit et
tu peux risquer la destruction merde oui
ou captain obvious marché et voilà un
biker alors la maison japonaise sauter
noms sautent huawei mais à temps parce
que le fait est que une fois que je suis
là à faut que je ok d'accord
ah ouais d'accord d'accord ok je pensais
que juste rester aux [ __ ] ont pas se
baisser
vous avez pas wow c'est toxique à mort
ça pue sévère
d'accord on peut y aller en mode discret
en coupant le gaz à mon avis ok parfait
enfin il faut y aller à mon avis on me
dit scanner regarder autour de nous ça
en plus d'essence taille venus [ __ ] le
feu
est-ce que je peux tu vois ce que je
peux tu as il est où
voix off aux questions auxquelles les
gens ont néanmoins d'infiltration
demande pas on y pose la demandeuse
et merde je crois que nous sommes
repérés alors qu'ils se les faire en
mode web on va prendre le gun du coup
moi je suis toujours sans le jeu tu sais
tu fais le mec discret qu'en termes et
discret puis dès qu'il ya des gens bons
docteurs peureux bonbons luz le sol où
sort le guen et c'est là le bret alors
y'a un mec qui arrive j'étais entendu
car l'enjeu est pris pour jackie chan
quoi regarder le plagiat jackie chan
allez hop ccp du coup maintenant merci
tu m'as dit que le chemin alors les
lentilles screamer à l'arrivée non ça va
ils sont pas fous ça va alors c'est quoi
ça ils lanternes
ouais c'est pour jeter et faire cramer
notamment ouf j'ai mis le feu monté par
ou par là non karkwa non complète des
titres n'a pas l'air solide of wales
adacore fallait vraiment jeté de long
terme de dents en fait très bien alors
vous voyez je suis demain je devine
avant même de faire à
il fallait peut-être de la ville au
dessus ipad vitraux dessus bon alors
fallait juste aller de l'autre côté puis
scopique trop large explique alors on va
chercher la l'option un peu compliqué de
vingt sept vitraux là ok je gâche mes
balles bêtement mais bêtement prendre sa
hotte du coup qu'est ce qu'on va pouvoir
faire
tu annules pas l'avis très solide la 10e
à merde faut que je paye ta vie tu là
j'ai vu un signe merde
oh [ __ ] mais si je passe de l'autre
côté on s'appuie aussi de l'autre côté
assez bon on va trouver un autre chemin
du coup de quelle vie tu me parles
[ __ ] de merde mais comment on fait
personne ne part mais j'ai déjà c'est de
la bêtise pas possible
peut-être qu'on leur internat et
traverser en fait avec long terme ouais
vas faire ça
ajustée à j'ai une idée de 20g l'idée de
2,20 c'est du gaz de l'autre côté et qui
dit gaz dits aaa
trop stylé tu souffres bien aux faux
admet rld
il est où je t'entends tous au
si la pomme où tu vas pin ou aux
mondiaux et la tipp 85 en enfer c'était
gratuit alors faut il y en a un petit
peu leur coin
il n'ya rien absolument rien absolument
rien absolument rien n'a rien foutu les
revenus continuent alors qu'est ce que
c'est que ça là des balles hier
galichian alors on verra ça plus tard
comme j'ai dit on fera un épisode
spécial les ché l'épisode qui fera de
vue et demi à savoir les jeunes
écrivains épouse
tiens
voilà fâche c'est une belle scène o o
fils de kamakazi y j'ai fait y bâtard
[ __ ] non mais regardez ils seront
dictés par une fille
casse toi là
et oui où on passe par le haut et les
skis pour les mauves éventuellement
quand j'en mets des ballots je crois que
c'était haribo que je leur lance al aïda
change rien du tout mais moi aussi je
vais des flèches en feu auquel faut
viser la tête vous à la tête on met des
faits de schott
y faut au jeu peut pas le tuer omer
demain même heure [ __ ] c'est bourré
d'action au web
vois tu peux nous fait que mater vous
que pendant que vous citez pas de
thématique reste stable
il aura sûrement mais bon je préfère
ramasser le ballon tu as vu je prends
mon temps ouais ouais tu es là que tu
fais c'était une tempête t tient un bar
dans le feu wesh mois jusqu'à tomber sur
toi quitte à mourir un petit commence
pas à pas de souci je t'en prie alors je
pense qu à mon avis avait quelque chose
alors il ya une boîte la vacance m boîte
ok alors va-t-on euros à mon avis dans
un petit truc pour nous un petit colis
afrique j'ai un petit rideau alors là
ici à mon avis un petit trophée à voir
je pense que tout le monde l'a vue venir
un feu parfait
ça fait un peu plus alors on avait un
point de compétence
on avait pour améliorer le pistolet a du
coup on peut améliorer le fusil ah oui
monsieur charger grande cape perso
j'accroche la boyne par une amère
instabilité de larmes
fran bouche davis dissiper classement le
gaz de propulsion pour réduire le recul
sur collants son mec de reboiser fin des
mentalités dans le chargement on va mur
la stabilité mais on est des gens soft
tu as fait et on a avait un point de
compétence à dépenser alors on va le
mettre au c'est quoi ça castagne heure
suisse et plus de gars lors des combats
sans y laisser votre peau et isa
poussière dès que pour aveugles les
ennemis et en vue à ça ça va être sympa
ap / b pour un peu puis y penser de la
poussière d'ange et des ennemis ouais je
suis marchands de second ont continué
mais voilà ok on va peut-être se la joue
en mode
tu fais quoi tête a raté tous montrés
jackie chan art est juste que j'aimerais
pas faire ça quand je suis là or voilà
ça y est on habitait la porte on a pété
la porte alors nous voici enfin à face à
des contrôles
alors oui non
alex
tu es là
wii la console est fichu
ouais
alors il va falloir passion quand tu vas
devoir manger fait graver tout lire sur
le panneau
maintenant c'est ok ça et toi tu vas
falloir que tu le trouves sur ces
vieilles tous ces panneaux soit environ
oh la vache [ __ ] escalade génial
moi ça va c'est mignon allait bien puis
en plus elle bouge tes fesses comme
escalader super bien c'est un truc qui
me feraient les gens qui mettent les
persos du jeu vidéo d'un bac mec alors
on a pas mal de matériaux de flèches ça
sans les nommer du coup qui va sûrement
juste derrière par où allons nous aurons
beau pas ici ah non par les flèches
oignons c'est chaud un savoureux louis
ou la vache à lait foot le stress
oh la vache j'espère que ça marchera
plus que ça
ouah
c'est vraiment s'il est sérieux allez
ouais on y est wen doit passer du chaud
au froid glacial là elle doit pas qui
fait du tout je sens qu'on va galérer
ses bords des juges pour des quoi le
fait qu'en parfait pourquoi c'est pas
normal à de la nation qu'est ce tu me
fais là bas je laisse le pad à fond tout
droit mais ça marche super alors voilà
je dépose pas manette wii elle a fait
l'aigle elle a fait loiseau elle a fait
le saut elle s'est envolée
mais laraque a acheté un mammifère
l'impact est fait pour être sur terre
voilà comment je carotte le jeu et
attends je vais le préchauffage
leprechaun emmerde je préfère des trucs
comme le cri de merde
et voilà c'est à lui de faire l'oiseau
aux [ __ ] enfin s'infiltrait aulas
juste un rêve il m'énerve la durée mec
de far cry dégage dégage
[ __ ] j'suis mais arthur que toi c'est
ça tu appelles tu vois je vois un mot de
ton que et ouais le que j'attaque
toujours drôle comme le but mais bon ça
c'est au [ __ ] c'est toute une base
d'accord je vois le délire non mais bon
on connaît les buy là bas on connaît les
baye fall et by on lui tape des skis non
mais ça a mentionné de losers laibow tu
fais mon boulot mais toi mon gars tu
prends la croix la grosse pour lui tu
vois le spécial
à l'origine avec cette arme c'est que ça
dure et ça fait absolument rien alors du
coup on a trouvé une caste merci roi bon
en fait de très loin c'est l'arc pour
être précis au revoir ouah ça c'est
stylé j'ai la flemme de monter récupérer
les trucs de l'autre main dessus sur
d'un bâtiment est sûrement des choses
secrètes ma foi on finit jeu à fond un
vraiment là dont on peut monter non
voilà il ya une échelle en boîte les
mecs les mecs les mecs le mec les mecs
on se détend on se détend là oh oh ok ok
là bas la wka caquette équipe comme il
me blague ils sont chiants avec leurs
noms mais mec mais ça va et ce que j'ai
fait je te dirai rien je préfère préfère
quand c'est moins le malin toi aussi
moi jamais moi jamais allé chez aller
chez aaa colloque de la flèche kaka
culotte flèche notamment fait
remarquable tant fait j'aurais dû monter
là-haut en fait pour l'aider c'est fait
exprès ou symbole da graça fait exprès
on ne doit pas montero ont très bien on
peut comprendre
oh [ __ ] on remettrait sa au ralenti la
flèche qui passa entre les deux camps le
regarder le mec s'acheter ce qu'il veut
bon on va y aller aux gunners c'est quoi
ce commence un peu à me saouler l'axema
rampe 2 secondes
mais honnêtement quand tu tires dans la
tête et mon hockey voilà comme ça va
tellement bon mais c'est ça mon
peut-être un truc important dans celui
ci on marque on peut y aller cela est
allé ramasser il y aura sûrement un
petit coffre caché
ouais c'est cool ou héros modifications
d'armes disponibles à milo a besoin dans
les camps oi qui avait deviné qu'elle
supprime murray c'en est un mais ça ça
allez hop
à bientôt monsieur alors ça ça tu
l'action
salut au revoir
assez des pierres
aulas et efficace le coup de pierres à
neutrons show spécial à croft mais bros
alors à quand tu es en fait je
réfléchissais si je pouvais tu es un
aigle oui je sais j'ai des verts non
c'est bon ça va nous toucher le feu ne
touchera pas ouais alors du coup [ __ ]
il va apparaître la tient au rct bois ça
oui dans les caisses vides fait un mec
qui me court après j'ai entendu c'est
pas mal ça du don
webb et ses courtes ça tu mets une
flèche et ils tuent tout seul gros bien
ouej par contre pensant qu'elle a du
coup au boss ayen boutures ouest
ok ok faut qu'ils chargent exhaustive
alors ok alors attendez on va se
concentrer esquive ah oui j'ai ce qu'il
a plus de moi je ne sais pas pratique
affaires j'avoue
ben on attendait pas tant qu il vienne
vraiment [ __ ] temps des balles au
chi et le caillou à rigole pas lui un
saint romain et je prends le bouclier
mois voilà j'aurai il disparaît au
d'accord pièces d'un arc bon ski fsa a
nato monsieur ok d'accord donc ça veut
dire pièces d'un art d'accord si je
trouve la seconde pièce donc sûrement
sur un second boss améliorer les
matériaux et les cadavres pour en
trouver voilà ok d'accord donc c'est
pourra débloquer des améliorations
d'armes à bail et dans la paix la non
non non j'ai cru d'accord ok
très bien bon on continue notre périple
ma foi hop hop hop hop emballé par ouf
là on aime gas oil and gas caisse
je me balade en territoire cubain ou
alors on va continuer
bon allez on finit juste ça et je pense
que la fin de l'épisode aura lieu ma foi
alors attendez il faut qu'on fasse pas
ouais alors qu'on aille vite fait voir
cette antenne là et qu'on pirates le
panneau et dès que c'est fait je pense
la maison sera fini c'est ouf
il ya un feu de camp déjà ici c'est pas
trop mal ouais bon tu as on n'a pas
encore débloqué trucs pour la rue donc
ça n'intéresse pas d'accord c'est tout
là haut
ok direction tout là haut on a une
tyrolienne à syncoor donc on peut
vraiment aller dans ce sens d'accord ok
mais ça va c'est pas trop on suit pas
trop dessus c'est cool ça fait encore
plus peur que les tours dans far cry
quoi et a quand même un petit côté faire
cracher trouve ni au niveau 2 du
déplacement plus vous savez les
tyroliennes et les tours ça me pense à
far cry bon c'est pas vraiment un truc
qu'on part quand même ça me fait penser
l'échelle va craquer avant qu'on avance
assez clair et net c'est obliger les
chefs va craquer non qu'on arrivera j'en
suis sûr voilà c'est qu'il ya la raison
ou la vache
là je sens qu est ce là pas de souci
parfait mais encore monter ou
je m'étonne que tu as peur ma pauvre
ah c'est moi qui contrôle quand même je
crois ouais c'est vrai qu'ils contrôlent
ok allez go à y font durer le suspense a
bien j'aimerais bien voir si je peux tu
en es après un aigle mon dieu oh non non
non pas c'est pas ça je voulais laisser
la liaison 1
quand je dis aux 1 je vais déjà les
journalistes lui l'artiste elle même
porte quoi juste lui dire aigles g10
aigre du coup ça fait un avec évasion
[ __ ]
ah ben ça me saoule et là on joue à
venir n'importe quoi ça j'imagine déjà
les contrôles non ça j'en ai trop l'est
pas alors on y va
n'empêche débarquant je me trompe et
avec les liaisons sam [ __ ] mais je
suis choqué encore j'ai trop le sommes à
me lasser même punition
[ __ ] vas-y
ouais bah ouais go à les leurs à rogner
[ __ ] ils le mettent vraiment tout
temps le panneau cole mec
au rang des moins bon paquet chamallow
ils avaient tous deux reconnus
ceci demande panneaux hockey la tour de
mes romans c'est un signal de l'émetteur
ensuite troubles canal d'urgence et
c'est d'avoir un signal clair sur ta
radio avant de diffuser leurs esprits et
tu sais qu'on croise tous les toits pour
toi ici merci
alors
c'est dit
non
alaa temps
ça c'est galère en lavage
voilà mayday mayday ici lara croft de
l'endurance
nous avons fait naufrage sur une île
dans le triangle du dragon nous avons
besoin d'être en urgence répondait
répondait à l'est mais il aimait est ici
lara croft de l'endurance et l'avion
november cherchions depuis le signal de
détresse lancé le votera navy ont
commencé à perdre espoir
nous y fut on à votre position
approximative mais il nous faudrait un
signal visuel incroyable fin du jeu
alors qu'est ce qui va poser faciès a
même esquissé un sourire
on
thaler qu'on avait
d'accord ok maintenant moi je pensais
aux petits trucs de détresse rouge qu'on
avait eue dans un des deux épisodes
d'avant quand j'avais loupé les billets
au moment où je dis tu es profit leurs
inquiétudes et rouge
je pensais plutôt à ça mais bon c'est le
feng on veut pourquoi pas en tout cas
les gens je vais acheter besoin de vous
aura plu on se retrouve demain pour
l'épisode number 4 et géologie